artificial intelligence is evolving and
fast can we keep up can we stay in
control and how concerned should we be
if we can't
[Music]
on the one hand advances in AI promise
to improve health care and boost our
economy on the other there's fears it
could threaten our democracy our very
existence if it falls into the wrong
hands AI is already changing the way we
live and work at a rapid pace and it
falls ultimately on the prime minister
to decide how we should deploy it in the
UK what are the risks and what are the
rewards I asked the Prime Minister about
this on a recent trip to Washington I'm
not going to get into this business of
of scaremongering people because I think
what people will say well hang on
there's a new technology which we don't
fully know yet what it's capable of
doing the creators themselves have
talked about risks on a scale and on
Parallel with nuclear war and pandemics
and when people hear that they'll
rightly be worried about that no but
that's why I've actually been bringing
the companies together to talk about
right guard rails to put in place to
prevent those kind of things from
happening and that's why I think it's
important that we do that so very very
important and I think the public will
want to hear this so what you're saying
is if it's not regulated properly it
could be on the scale of equivalent to
nuclear risk it could kill humans we
have to monitor it I have to regulate it
it's absolutely right that we put guard
rails in place because the technology is
enormously powerful it's that extreme
power that's got people worried but
should we be I'm here at the University
of Southampton to talk to Professor Dame
Wendy Hall she is a leading computer
scientist in this country and the AI
skills Champion for the UK so no one
better placed to talk about this
technology and how it's going to affect
our future
Dame Wendy thanks for joining us on the
show
we're also excited you've come to
Southampton I'm delighted to be here
um now you've had an extraordinary
career as one of the world's leading
computer scientists but you don't look
to me like a classic computer geek if I
may say how difficult was it for you to
make it in in what has always been a
very mild dominated world I taught maths
and you know for engineers at Oxford
Brooks Oxford Polly as was and then I
came back to Southampton to teach NASA
to teach training College I'm the head
of the Mass Department the personal
computers were coming out at the time
and he said oh you're a mathematician
you can do computing uh you know we need
to do a basic that's the basic
programming language course so I took a
Commodore Pet Home One Summer and taught
myself the basic programming language
I've never been a great programmer but I
began to see the magic and the magic was
being able to put photos videos text on
a computer yeah against all the odds I
managed to build a group up around doing
this type of work and that's why I'm
considered a pioneer of multimedia
and hopefully then I got this I started
to see this stuff about how you make
links between documents on computers
it's called hypermedia and I met Tim
berners-lee at a conference he was
talking about the web he hadn't called
it that then I was talking about the
system we built here here the hypermedia
system we built here and we've you know
been working together on and off ever
since but but I got this idea that if
you could actually get information on a
device in those days it was a computer
and be able to click on a piece of
information and go somewhere else
anywhere else in the world
to download that information onto your
machine your now your phone how exciting
that would be what I'd like to do today
is get you to explain to people in a way
I couldn't possibly ever begin to what
artificial intelligence is in this next
Frontier
but you clearly it really excites you in
the 40 years you've been doing all of
this does it scare you as well no never
I will come on to this there are threats
from AI
um but there was and actually
you know there were threats from what we
were doing on the internet with the
World Wide Web we we didn't realize at
the time we we you just assumed that
people are going to do good things with
it
so when we moved into the
2000s and the social the web became
interactive so you could write to it
without having to learn a programming
language
um and social media started to arrive we
really didn't have any idea what bad
things people would do with it or you
know both you know I I asked everything
that's bad about Society is written
large on the internet it happens so fast
and it's somehow that people also people
have seem to have they lose their moral
compass in a way you know they seem to
feel they can do something in social
media they wouldn't do it in real life
no can you explain to us what we mean by
the term artificial intelligence
well it's changed a lot since it was
invented in the 60s the UK likes to
claim the invention of artificial
intelligence through Alan Turing and his
paper in the 50s and cam machines think
and his argument that um you know you
wanted his Turing tests can you tell the
difference between a machine asking
questions and people asking questions or
answering your questions artificial
intelligence was it really was born out
of the world of philosophy
during was philosophizing could we
actually build create using software and
maybe Hardware as well specialist
Hardware machines that could out-think
humans or at least be as in intelligent
as we are and that was the beginning of
um that field
then as the mission machines became more
powerful the the definition of the word
subtly changed it became it wasn't
really that we're trying to replicate
the human brain or even to think about
although there are some experiments to
do that or even to think about what
intelligence means because that's what
the philosophers were thinking about in
the first place it was more about how
can we build systems that can think for
themselves right and given an objective
actually think their way through it so
um we as I said we develop expert
systems and along the way people like
Jeff Hinton who was originally at the
University of Edinburgh he was
developing this idea of we could maybe
do that using what we call neural
networks which is really mimicking how
the neurons in the brain talk to each
other now with neural networks they're
trying to think of how to mimic how not
to build a human brain but how those
networks fire off of each other to
create complicated networks out of which
information and knowledge emerges just
on the neural networks so people can
understand I think the concept of how
you program a computer to do to do
something or or writing code to mimic
human intelligence but then something
these neural networks something news
emerging isn't it that computers seem to
be able to learn and develop
independently from being programmed is
that where it's going that's where it's
going and that's what people are
frightened of people to understand it is
because you explain that because
absolutely actually just think of it
like how a child learns it's it's
actually not much different to that
all right children I mean our human
brains are still far more far better and
far more sophisticated than anything we
can build today
but when you think about how a child
learns you don't you can't understand
what partner is people study forever how
children pick up on things when they're
little and as they get bigger how they
pick up on language and how they pick up
on your face that is essentially how
these machines are working so why in the
broadest sense today Wendy would you say
AI can help us
because
um the sort of AI we're using at the
moment machine learning generative AI it
works on it's trained on huge amounts of
data and can do that in a way that we
can't do so for in in medicine when it's
looking at scans cancer scans or eye
scans
it could do many many many hundreds and
be much more accurate than a human being
doesn't mean that the Radiologists who
do those scans today will lose their
jobs we still need Radiologists they can
do other things but what AI will do I
think is is some of the the menial stuff
you know just just looking Time After
Time are images more accurately and
faster because they can it can absorb so
much data what about better government
because do you think decision makers
eventually will be able to draw on the
wisdom of these hugely intelligent
machines to to make better decisions as
well do you think AI could improve our
politicians I I think so I mean
I can say this can't tell us about I
mean politicians often talk about things
they don't know anything about and and
partly that's because they're given a
lot of stuff to read and they don't have
time to assimilate it and one thing you
can do with the generative AI is give it
a file and ask it to summarize it for
you and talk to you can talk to it about
what are the most important things in
that file and it'll it'll give you that
analysis so it helps you process
information so that you can be more
efficient absolutely yeah I think I need
a bit of that
and when you think about what we're
going to have is that sort of AI linked
to a search engine uh like Google or
Bing and then you see you'll be able to
ask questions to get the facts back and
some analysis and it'll it'll it'll
reply in a natural language that's why
it feels so intelligent I mean I I read
a very interesting essay this week
um that said AI could be the most
important and best thing that's ever
happened to us that Civilization has
ever created this essay argue that it
was on par with breakthroughs like
electricity and and microchips do you
see it like that Wendy I do I do but
we must we must just
how profound is it to I mean is it the
most transformational thing civilization
will see in
ever because it might be the end of ever
no but but I'm just trying to get it
into my head like how profound a moment
this could be for civilization we're now
seeing how we can use it to
create Better Lives for people and I
think also equal playing fields too if
we get it right for the developing
countries as well as developed countries
I think that's so important it will give
us the power to do all sorts of things
that we haven't even dreamed of it will
create new jobs that we have no idea yet
what they're going to be
um
is it the last thing humans will ever
invent because then AI will just invent
the machines and invent stuff
there are people who say exactly that
because if if the machines take over
then it's they don't need us right
well they don't even have to actually be
clever than us to to become our masters
because
if they can do things better than us
that doesn't mean they have to have that
much of an understanding of what they're
doing it's it's so it's all about
managing taming the tiger that we've
created
and that's why regulation is so
important
what about the risk of
Bad actors in this and what I mean is
when
you know that the Prime Minister
described it to me last week as
enormously powerful technology that we
are creating what if that goes into the
hands of someone who wants to do harm be
that
Putin
president XI Kim jong-young of North
Korea how how could
Bad actors use it against us well
um in the short term like next year we
will see a growth in disinformation
the Deep fakes of this world because AI
makes it very easy to do that
um you you can just get the tools off
off the internet to and it's getting
harder and harder to detect that a video
or a photo or a piece of text has been
faked
um I I see this as something we've we've
we need we've got two well two major
elections coming up next year the US UK
and the the you've got elections as well
I see this as as a threat to democracy
in the sense that we've got to help
people understand what where they're
getting the messages from we have to
understand how to check our sources
we all have to understand that and not
just believe everything because it's
appeared on the internet but next year
is very soon I mean I know so I think
that's more important than worrying
about an existential threat in 100 years
time but I'm not saying the existential
threat isn't there it is very unlikely
at the moment I think or let's say it's
unlikely at the moment but it's a
possibility and so we have to prepare
for the fact that we we are
um we're keeping the the AI under our
control so that we don't become the
slaves to that Master and which is where
the regulation comes in what does the
what do governments need to do between
now and
a general election maybe in October and
then a U.S election in November what do
they do between here and now and then to
try and they well I think we're in the
we are in a good place to think about it
and if it were if it were me if I was
prime minister the global Summit in the
Autumn would be all about this right
okay
because what I would I mean you've
already got the AI task force is set up
um we've got money coming out like the
money we've got here at Southampton to
look at trustworthy reliable responsible
trustworthy AI there's a lot of money
being announced today the Prime Minister
that 100 million there's there's money
coming out and what we need as people to
quite quickly pull together the
technology that's used to detect fakes
and to
um to ensure that somebody's coming from
a trusted source and I think I have to
say as ever journalists and newspapers
are have a big responsibility here I
know that all um you know creditable
journalists will check their sources and
we that has to be something that you
know we make France and Central and I
would I would say let's discuss that in
the ultimate something really real and
tangible and get
task force is going that are looking at
the technology to help with that really
I think of it like um
oh I won't say a war scenario I think we
should think of it as a clear and
present danger
and at the same time set in motion the
global discussions about how we regulate
AI in the future you talked about
existential threat
um
this is about AI technology developing
more rapidly than expected uh
to the point where that technology
becomes more
intelligent than humans what would be
the significance of that moment Wendy if
and when that happens well it used to be
called The Singularity this has been
talked about for a long time it's not
something that's just emerged it's you
know academics philosophers people
interested have been talking about this
for a long time and there's a university
called the singularity in America we
think about what would happen if
machines
overtook human beings in terms of
intelligence
and as I said before actually
see none of the stuff we've got today
has any sentience it doesn't know what
it's doing right it does what it's
programmed to do and then it's because
of these huge networks it generates
information in ways we can't unravel and
find out how it did it
um
so they don't have machines don't have
to be in more intelligent than us or
more no more than us
to be to be able to generate themselves
and that's I think the real if if the
machines can can spawn other machines
that are you know this that are more
intelligent then uh we we lose control
of what's going on
um and you you remember 2001 with um you
know Hal saying um or I can't do that
Dave right and you couldn't turn hell
off because Hal's driving the ship yeah
yeah right we've got this can we turn it
off could we stop it if it was a real
imminent can we stop it can we turn it
off can we unplug it you can't no you
can't exactly like that but you can you
can you could do things to block it and
that's another discussion that we need
to have because you know to really you'd
have to turn the internet off you'd
probably have to turn the electricity
Supply off
but Wendy does it does it
we start we're not anywhere how excited
you were about technology and of all the
developments
does it frighten you the idea
that machines become out of human
control
yes of course it does I would be I
couldn't say it doesn't we aren't
anywhere near that right the headline
that said we've got two years to save
the world was very misleading and the
quote was taken out of context
but I do believe we're at a point where
we can see how things could get out of
control
in
Generations down the line
so I believe firmly and I'm totally with
the government on this I'm glad we're
taking a lead that we need to think
about global regulation in the area of
AI in the same way as we think about
climate science if we think about
nuclear threats and we think about
chemical biological welfare Warfare it
is at that level that we have to discuss
it but you just going back to Mark
Clifford because you you just mentioned
him in your your answer there because
he's the PM's advisor advisor at the
moment on AI and he's I I listened to
that interview and it was of course Very
nuanced but he did say in it that the
moment when computers could become more
intelligent than humans could come
within two years
and he said it could kill many humans
um
what did you make of that you just I
think it was I thought that was
overreaction
we I I don't believe we are at that
stage I think we could see how it could
happen
right I mean that you know it's um how
could it kill humans though oh by
developing a drug that kills us all
but then if someone persuades us all to
take it
I mean we have huge regulation on the
pharmaceutical industry for this very
reason right and we all know the scare
Stories the thalidomides and all the
other stories where drugs have got
through I mean you know we're still
discussing the kovid vaccines in in
terms of uh how how they were tested
um and
um
that that is very regulated that
industry and so AI needs to be probably
as regulated as that and the two come
together because
um you know AI
Technologies and our machines can can
develop say develop a new drug
and in the wrong hands it could be sold
as a great cure for such and such you
can think of scarce scenarios
but we aren't at that stage yet because
Jeffrey Jeffrey Hinton who you talked
about earlier who's the Godfather you
know the Godfather of AI from it
developers from Embassy he he said
recently he thought it was running out
of control he said he quit Google didn't
he because he did he said he no longer
wanted to be involved in the work and he
said I've got the quote here when he
said the idea of this stuff could
actually get smarter than people a few
people believe that but most people
thought it was way off and I thought it
was way off I thought it was 30 to 50
years or even longer away obviously I no
longer think that so how how fast do you
think we could cross that rubricon I
don't think it's two years but I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna come up with the
name that's what happened to Matt
Clifford a number yeah um I think that
um people like Jeffrey Hinton I think I
I think having having said well I've
invented this and I'm running away
because it's all coming
um come on we need your brain to help us
help us tackle it to make sure I believe
that if we get the regulation right we
can we can keep you keep it under
control are you disappointed that he
I'm disappointed in the way he did it
yeah because uh yeah okay so I could
he's claiming he could he was part of
the cause the development of this and
now he's walking away when when actually
we probably need him most we're hosting
the first Global conference about how we
might regulate AI
um and this is the Google deepmind CEO
Demis hasabis put out a statement so
mitigating the risk of Extinction from
AI should be a global priority alongside
other societal scale risks such as
pandemics and nuclear war when I asked
the PM about that and about regulation
and the co he he didn't deny that he he
sort of acknowledged this existential
risk but you you were saying that
shouldn't be the priority right now I
think I I do believe but it is we it is
a huge priority don't get me wrong it is
a huge problem we just start on that
path now I think we have short term risk
that we really need to think about for
next year we need to start talking about
global regulation you don't do that in a
short period of time the other thing
which we did we sort of touched on
briefly earlier you I don't believe you
can have this Global discussion without
people like the Chinese yeah and well
maybe the Russians that's a different
issue uh but definitely the Chinese the
Chinese have this technology already
don't think that they don't yeah yeah
right they have it and maybe even better
than ours you know it could it could be
more developed
um than ours so
we I firmly believe we've got to have
them at the table not necessarily at
this Autumn meeting but the last thing I
I really don't think we should be
setting up a situation where we have a
meeting about something that's just as
important to them as it is to us they
have different cultural values but
they're just as worried about the
existential threat from AI as we are
right they're just as worried about
ethics and AI as we are and we can't
have a global agreement that only only a
third of the world are signed up to
right do you think
it would be beneficial to slow down the
progress to allow the systems if you
like the regulatory Systems Technology I
think it will slow down itself a bit
there's no business model for this year
these companies have got to make money
and also it takes a huge amount of money
and compute power
to analyze the whole of the internet the
last they did it in 21. gpt4 was trained
on the internet as it was in
2021. it is phenomenal
for not it is phenomenally expensive to
do that unlike Google who and and
Microsoft being through the internet all
the time to get the information they
want for the link for the search engine
you can't do that with this job so so I
I personally think it's going to slow
itself down okay so which side of the
line do you stand that AI will save us
or AI will be our end save us it'll save
us and Wendy I've got one final thing I
wanted to talk about are the Frontiers
which is I this is also Elon Musk
company neurolink how to insert
microchips into people's skulls to treat
conditions and the chips have been test
on monkeys and they're designed to
interpret signals produced in the brain
and relay the information around your
body via Bluetooth
um apparently a test on humans has been
improved in the US what's your take is
that hopeful technology well again you
see this for people with disability
right
but if we think genitive AI is
potentially an existential threat just
imagine a world where computers can read
your brain waves
that's what this is about what they
control me to do things I might want to
do you can certainly they can certainly
know what you're thinking
now at the moment the messages are going
one way right the machines are reading
the brain waves whether they could then
insert something into the brainwave
which there have been many science
fiction films about
memento's one
so that when people ask me what's the
next generation of AI we should be
thinking about that's the one I always
pick because I've seen it in the
research labs for years now
but there was a case wasn't there where
a man from the Netherlands had been
paralyzed and he I mean yeah for him
that isn't it's amazing it's a mirror so
this is why I say save us yeah but we
need I mean it's another form of
completely different form of AI okay but
when you bring that yeah but we have to
be able to regulate that as well so the
advantages of parallel paralyzed past
and can walk again which is for that
individual without sight you can see
again or here here again
yeah I mean that's wonderful amazing but
the risk is that that the computer then
controls your brain or at least knows
exactly what you're thinking and you
think and then what manipulates you yeah
I mean turns us into an army of
zombies at the moment as I said it's
going the producer reading the brainwave
reading them they can't write to them
yet what could it do if it could read
your brain well I understand what you're
thinking so I'll think out thinking in
that sense
uh well I mean also you could I mean
would you want other people to be
reading your brain because if your
computer can read it then you would not
you see if your computer can read it
then other people can get from the
computer what you're thinking so you're
into a world where I mean I I find that
world a bit scary I have to say I want
to make sure that we really understand
what we're doing with that technology so
I would like to think that this is a new
technology that hasn't yet emerged into
the mainstream but it's definitely
coming so I would in a way think ahead
of the current game so rather than
thinking too much about how we regulate
generative AI because that's not
intelligence at all in any sense really
um as things stand I would think much
more about how would you regulate an
industry with you've got machines
reading brainwaves because that requires
that's not just software that's cyber
physical
so it's another another layer of
Regulation Jesus now has more risk than
benefit then no no again the benefits
are huge
but it's all about how we learn how we
learn
to work with the machines you've done
this for four decades you've been yeah
is this the most exciting transformative
time for technology in your lifetime and
that blows my mind even asking that
question when I think about you know
being at University I didn't even have a
computer or mobile phone you know to
where we are now but is it the most
well that's I actually was had my mind
blown by the internet and the web I mean
don't forget I was right at The Cutting
Edge of that
just think what life was like without
that
just in quite peaceful to be honest all
right thank you so much for talking to
us about it and um it was extremely
interesting and I think that people will
have learned a lot so thank you so thank
you thank you for coming down and just
taking the time thanks so much thank you
Wendy well I hope you enjoyed this
week's conversation with Dame Wendy Hall
plenty of food for thought in that and
if you scan the QR code on your screen
right now you can listen to the Beth
Rigby interviews podcast each week I
take a look at the highlights of my
interviews and there are some extra bits
and pieces in there too that'll be on
the Sky News app or wherever you get
your podcasts well that's all for this
week's show from the University of
Southampton thanks so much for joining
us
foreign
[Music]